but this brings me to the general lefty
argument because i was watching this
video um from casey neistat it's an
older video
and it's called something like being
rich for being versus being poor
okay and he basically talks about how he
was reading this article
that said this guy makes 1.2 million a
year and he hates his life he's
miserable his office sucks
and he's unhappy and they talk about
like a janitor who loves his job and
feels so helpful he's like a janitor
at a hospital okay and they bring up a
really good point about purpose and
fulfillment
basically if you're a real estate you
know broker or whatever
agent and you're making millions of
dollars do you feel fulfilled like are
you actually helping the world be a
better place
probably not just so what the guy said
was when i die will anyone care that i
got a two percent
you know return on my investment right
but the janitor is saying
i may not be a doctor but without me
people will will literally die
like i need to clean up medical waste
and make sure the hospital is
functioning in such a way that the
doctors can bring these people in safely
and securely
and so what i'm doing is very important
so anyway purpose people need a purpose
in in this video he talks about how he
says
you know they claim money can't buy you
happiness but it can
and the the reason he gives is that
everybody's trying to find happiness
love purpose and fulfillment and others
these are like
you know human desires and then he
mentions that
then he like folds this thing up and it
says healthcare
clothes you know housing and he was like
when you
when you are rich you can just pay for
all of these problems to go away
and then these other things you're just
free to explore so money can literally
solve your problems and i i take i i
disagree i humbly disagree and this goes
back to a lot of what we're saying about
the far left about aoc
think about what healthcare means today
think about what housing means today
you know so standards of living
everyone's used to the standards of
living in this country are so incredibly
high
the only reason you think your health
care is a problem is because you know
someone has it better
that's a good point think about it
that's a good 100 years ago if you got
cancer
what do you do you know what yes i'll
die more importantly though
it's they don't know that there's people
in the world
that have it less well exactly that's
what i mean that's the other side
but that's that's what everyone ignores
they only
see someone that's doing better
capitalism is so bad
is it or or are you just clueless to
what's really going on in the world
because that's what i'm seeing the meme
is
graduates with you know feminist dance
degree and then complains capitalism
isn't working
but you know when i watch this video i'm
like if you
stubbed you know if you got a a cut in
the middle of the woods
you know two or three hundred years ago
on an important journey yeah you'd look
down and go oh man
guess i'll die yeah i'm kidding but
that's like the the
could if you're if you're not lose your
leg near water where you can
open like take out the sliver of the you
know you stub your toe on a piece of
wood
i guess a bit of wood you could
cauterize actually i have no idea
i i cut my foot my ankle on coral when i
was 12.
just just cut it open it was bad i mean
i got it sewn up
everything was fine seven months later i
got a
bone infection whoa in my right hip i
was bedridden
for for months i couldn't i couldn't
walk so it was really bad
but that's the kind of thing that we
don't even think about it's like sure
yeah exactly if i cut it like i could
have
you know maybe sewn the wound shut
whatever would be fine but the infection
that god that got me later on in life
i'm not saying people are clueless
people should be resigned to poverty
that's i'm i'm just saying keep some
perspective
you know recognize perspective is
everything just because other people
might have it better
doesn't mean you have it worse yeah
we've gradually improved everything
i was watching a rerun of outer limits
that show from like the 90s
because i just watched every i love that
show one of them it's these two guys who
get teleported they get they get time
traveled to the civil war
okay one of the guys is an actual medic
and so
they he gets captured by the
confederates he's dressed like a yankee
for a reenactment
and they force him to perform a surgery
on a guy who got shot in the leg
and they're like we need you to amputate
and he goes no i don't need to amputate
and the
the colonel whatever is like if you do
not amputate this man will die and he
goes
this man will not die because he had his
bag with him and he pulled a little tube
of like
you know neil sporn or something some
antibacterial yeah it was rubbed on the
leg and was like
good to go and then the next day like
the guy's like you saved my life and
saved my leg it was some simple
something we take for granted that we go
we you go to walgreens and you're like
how much for this tube i stubbed my toe
i'm like that'll be two dollars and
you're like
two dollars right fine
or you like take some mouthwash and you
like splash it on because you're like
well i guess i'll use this
right and it's antisept it's antiseptic
so
far i look at a lot of these lefties
that
think they should be rockefeller they
think they should be donald trump
and i'm like no no no there will always
be people
who are better who are richer i mean
it's there's one person
out of 7.2 billion that is the richest
person
literally not everybody can be
completely equal in all these terms
you can be equal in poverty right go to
a country like venezuela even there
you're not completely equal there's
still wealthy people who have military
power and control and they'll they'll do
the
well i mean his dad was rich and it's
like as true
okay well then think about your great
grandchild
think about that that child and be
make sure that they're set up think
about them don't think about yourself
anymore
think about how trump got that
he and his great grandfather came here
he wasn't he wasn't
super wealthy i mean i'll talk about it
more tomorrow i don't want to like
but but basically it's like you got
that's what you got to do
plan for the future think about the
future and be like i need to better
myself today so that when my child grows
up
they're going to be better off whoa whoa
whoa adam that sounds like you're
talking some white supremacy here
planning for the future yeah whatever
that stupid article i
i don't want to give credence to that
that's stupid
i don't know what you're like joking
about it's stupid this is a serious
issue like
if you if you seriously think that
there's other people out there that are
doing better than you
and that's what you're focused on your
focus is wrong you need to focus on
yourself
that's what people don't want to do
anymore and that pisses me off well well
well i'm seeing it everywhere
but but hold on what al the way i put it
is if you look at somebody
and they're better off than you and your
reaction is i deserve what they have
your next question should be what do i
have to do
to accomplish it that's exactly right
boom and
and then more importantly within the law
because some people would be like i got
me a knife i'm gonna go take what i
deserve
and some people are gonna be like i got
me a molotov and i'm gonna go demand the
government give me what i deserve
you gotta earn it you deserve what you
build and then they say but capitalism
is exploitative
you know what man you're free
you are free i'll tell you what why
don't any of these people
understand entitlement do they buy a
shirt do they do they wear
shirts do they do you want to wear a hat
do you
use headphones do you do you communicate
on your phone
every day you know there's they they try
to they turn such a blind eye
to the the the benefits of what it has
brought
us down to antiseptic which is
super important go ahead what we should
start a fund
raise a bunch of money to buy a big plot
of land
and build a commune and invite all of
them to live there for free and
bask in true utopian equality
what would they do well if you wanted
you got to grow it
but they did that they did that you you
told me about that i know i'm saying
let's make it a thing
it's like so all these people are like
we didn't we demand equality and
socialism bro we got a socialist commune
ready to go
exactly as you dreamed it up and if you
work hard you'll be fine
and i literally mean in the best ways
possible but you know i expect what
happened warlord
no well yeah someone would show up with
a gun and be like i'ma sit right here
and you give me grapes
yep and then they're no but like let's
say we we actually set up a
real commune because they they exist
there's one it's really really great
okay they they you um they all vote on
who they let in
and they have like a limit on how many
people are allowed but it really does
function properly i've seen there's
there's a few and
they exist over in europe also some in
the uk i got madrid and some here
yeah yeah yeah but they built it and
they work hard they work hard
every single day you don't stop working
but they love it
people don't want to work either but
hard work but it's another one of those
lists
but check it out the people who actually
started these communes
they're hard workers that's true they
invited in hard workers
and the people who don't work hard are
free to go at any time no no our
are kicked out if you don't work hard in
those kind of environments you are not
welcome
you don't get food and then you leave
so they're like no they're very strict
yeah i've i've watched a few things on
those
those kind of places and they are strict
if you don't do the work
you're not welcome there and that makes
sense to me what i'd love to do is i'd
love to set up
a little commune and i will pay your
your travel ticket
in style you'll come down you can bring
whatever you want
and then get to tell in that field baby
you want food tomorrow you better work
chop chop up it's up at sunup
go to bed go to bed you know three or
four hours after sundown
after you've finished all your work and
uh if that's what you're into some
people really are into that
but it's like if people just need to
experience
hard work because like i told you like i
had friends who did and they immediately
were like
wow i like being american i like
cheap chinese plastic crap i don't want
to work
these people i tell you what man in new
york city now they're moving out because
these jobs are remote
could you imagine what it must be like
to work at buzzfeed no
listen i would never i used to i when i
was 18 i got a job
at american eagle airlines which is
american airlines regional
you know branch okay and it was uh eight
hours a day
lifting like 30 to 50 000 pounds of
luggage
all day every day just loading up you
know planes or if you're in the bathroom
everybody hated that it wasn't so bad
actually
the reason people don't like the bag
room is because you sit in front of a
conveyor belt
watching bags and you you have like a
certain zone so you're like these cities
you have to grab their bags load them up
okay and so it actually wasn't that bad
because sometimes you'd sit around doing
nothing
when you're loading planes however
planes come in every like 40 minutes
right so you're constantly going to a
different spot no no when the planes are
coming in 40 minutes you have actually
like a 15-minute break in between
all right you know like a 20-minute
break so i do this job
hard work all day every day the first
time
i saw a news office i just busted out
laughing
laughing i walk in half the chairs are
empty and i'm like oh wow a lot of empty
chairs oh another step working from home
and i'm like working from home yeah do
they have to come in
i mean you know we like it when they do
but not really
what do they do um you know they just do
click baits
couple articles per day like what is you
know so this person does our music blog
they would write like i just you know
advice articles are like
oh yeah it's like i listened i i smoked
a bunch of weed and then listened to
this old sublime album and dude it was
crazy
and they were just right like you know
which they got paid
advice like 30k a year which was double
what you would make lifting heavy bags
but i'll tell you what some of these
companies it's like
you write listicles about brad pitt's
junk like
look at all these bulges here's a list
and they're getting paid 30 40k a year
i'm not gonna produce a lot of money for
new york city but relative to somebody
making minimum wage
lifting heavy bags i couldn't help but
bust out laughing this is what
you consider work wow
and i'll tell you what man i work for
these companies
you do you like i gotta be real they
have no idea what they're doing
half the time they're sitting around
doing nothing right
not even just sitting there and i'm like
what are you doing i don't know
you're gonna you're gonna write i'll
tell you what i am doing i'm getting
paid
that's right yup on salary
and that's just boring that's a crazy
thing about the media industry
that when they fall apart and they fire
everybody yeah wonder why
it's like these people aren't producing
things it's not real it's it's not
it's not real man the media bubble it
does feel like it's crumbling
here's here's my solution i've figured
out everybody
i've figured out a way it's the internet
to save the news industry
i'm going to recreate the vice office
but instead of people sitting around
confused at the time i'm going to make
them
uh make bird houses they're going to be
building bird houses instead of sitting
around doing nothing
hear me out we sell the bird houses make
a profit
oh and then of course whenever they have
time they can write one of their stupid
articles about
this is great you know smoking pot and
listening to sublime or something
no down time if you're not reading the
news you're building a birdhouse
you got that that's pretty good there
you go that's pretty good we sell those
bird houses online
maybe we can do like uh crochet and
stuff
and yeah make scarves make we'll make
beanies whatever you're good at
everybody must be must be making beanies
i like this yeah idea the beanie idea
you must be you must
you must be manufacturing to be fair
though my my vision
of a functioning media company would
would be literally
everything you do is work and so this
was actually something they tried doing
with vice but never took off
where it was like when we would go out
on
uh documentary shoots for say oh we're
going to a riot you know
we're gonna we're gonna go we went to
ukraine okay and they asked
can you film other things with your
downtime like you got to eat right
can you film yourselves eating hey we're
in ukraine
and they just served us up some cabbage
and and we're going to eat
crane cabbage yeah yeah look how excited
we are but then
boom article not an article video oh
video because then you can make really
quick videos where like here's what food
is like in this place
it's actually really clever that's great
never did it never
but it was a good idea it's like can you
can you always be working
yeah but they actually did a show that
was like people really loved about food
i remember what the guy's name was
action bronson or something was that his
name yeah yeah and he did he did the
food thing yeah i think he did it yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah everyone really loved it i guess
he's pretty funny yeah man but uh
wow such little work in that city of new
york city
i'd rather do that you want to hire me
to do that i'll fly around and
find all the the crazy you want to quit
the podcast
no no um but we will you know
when we expand we're going to do silly
food stuff and you know skateboarding
and whatever
but i'll tell you what we have a serious
problem in this country with general
the general balance of wealth and labor
i i think that's that's actually a fact
so that's why like i'm pretty left when
it comes like the wealth inequality
stuff
yeah and there's a there's a lot of
things that i think are you know strange
that conservatives would support or that
liberals would support
that are probably contradictory like
listen
their wealth their their wealth and
equality problems in this country
the easiest way to put it is why is
someone getting paid
three times as much to write about brad
pitt's junk
compared to someone who actually will
build or fix something good point
i tell you man look when you're like uh
running your own business
doing like carpentry or plumbing or some
kind of actual trade you'll make good
money
but why is a senior editor who sits at a
computer collecting articles from other
people
and then just reads them and says i'm
going to publish this getting paid more
they're not making anything we could
literally just delete all of these
companies we'd be better off for it
probably
look some news a lot of we need news we
need real journalism what we don't need
are these trash blogs you know like
buzzfeed and fox buzzfeed springs to
mind
yeah buzzfeed what how do we rebalance
that you know when i was little
i always agreed that it's crazy that
baseball players that you know
basketball players get paid all this
money
and scientists and tradesmen and
firefighters don't and that's like a
common lefty kind of perspective what is
that
um do you know there's a ceo that gave
up
his salary to take like a crazy cut
do you know who i'm talking about super
stressful i i don't remember no
it was a company in seattle right where
he was talking about it he was like look
i i
i wouldn't my company wouldn't exist
without the workers
so i'm gonna i'm gonna get pay myself
significantly less
but this was and all of that it's not
real
there's i have to pull it back up but
i'm pretty sure
it was because people don't understand
how businesses work okay i'm not going
to say anything specific about this guys
i don't know the specific guy you're
referencing but i think i do okay let me
just tell you something when you own a
corporation
okay you can say i'm gonna reduce my
salary to
you know 50 000 a year to be the same as
the people
um um accountant yes just issue it all
as profits the end of the year
right so you can publicly announce your
salaries being reduced
right i'm not i'm i'm i'm not saying
that like look if you work
if you get a job at a company and
they're like what's your what's your
salary requirement you say 50 grand a
year and they say you're hired
and then you're like but it turns out
the ceo makes 5 million dollars
that's that's too bad that's his company
you don't got to work there what i mean
is
why is a person literally writing about
you know
going to a rave and taking acid and then
passing out in the bathroom and getting
paid
more or at least the same as a dude who
literally builds houses
like if you if you are the lowest tier
apprentice
you know showing up and being like i
have no idea this works but i can carry
tools for you you deserve more than
someone who's like
i saw brad pitt's junk today he was
popping out in a tabloid magazine and
here's a list of all the times a
celebrity's junk has appeared
why why are you getting paid for that to
be fair
to be fair why do people care about that
well that's that's what i was going to
say to be fair
people care right and people are more
willing to essentially
buy or or cater to those products and
that's why they make so much money
but i kind of feel like there's
something wrong with that
and i don't know if you can actually
solve it because then we get into the
conversation about capitalism you know
free market versus
controlled or command economy yeah but
it does it does bum me out
that it's part of the conversation we've
had before that if humans ever shake
hands with aliens
it'll be not because they overcame
nuclear weapons but because they
overcame the xbox
or that's playstation would be more
accurate right considering xbox but at
the time when that quote was said xbox
was up there you know i was like
hey everybody's got an xbox but not but
it is true man it bums me out that we
allocate so much of our energy as humans
to dumb nonsense that's true i don't
know how you solve that though because
free will individuality that's why we
need a space race
that's why we need trump's what's the
artemis project
that's why elon musk and then going from
the moon to mars
yeah because we need to inspire a
culture to look beyond
writing stories about you know doing
drugs at a rave yeah everyone's so
complacent in this
this world that we live in right now
that's that's an issue too you know
people are comfortable
and then are so comfortable they're
forgetting what it's like
to not be comfortable they're they're
forgetting what it's like to not have
all these amazing amenities that
this world now offers us to everyone
most people you need water go get some
water you could
in in some states it's illegal to to say
no to someone who's asking for water
i'm talking about arizona specifically
um there might there's probably other
places you know
maybe texas you know somewhere in the uh
it's along the south there's a legal two
escalators no no
to deny someone water like if you walk
in and say ah water i need water it's
like okay here you go they have to get
it to have to give it
because like a place like arizona you
could really die yep you could thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
itunes and spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode